Welcome back everyone is going to be my marvel
Hawkeye trailer video. Happy holidays obvious
it;s a very holiday themed series. This will
be my quick reaction video. I Will do a longer
full breakdown of this tomorrow. There's a
bunch of Easter eggs in here. They're basically
doing Hawkeye volume 4, so I'll explain that
too. If you're brand-new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I be doing videos for all the episodes. Just
like I did for Loki. Just like I'm doing for
marvel's what if. All the other marvel Disney
plus series. Obviously one of the biggest
reveals is Hailee Steinfeld as the Kate Bishop
version of Hawkeye. I'll also explain what's
going on with the whole black widow crossover
because of the black widow post credit scene
with yelena belova, because the way that Val
basically gave her orders to kill Hawkeye.
When he says during the trailer his past as
Ronin is finally catching up with him. Although
I think is a little bit more going on when
it comes the whole Val of it. Many people
want him dead though clearly. I'll start at
the beginning of this and go through shot
by shot talk about Easter eggs obviously probably
one of the funniest things in here is the
Captain America theme musical a timeless hero
of course they would have a musical telling
Captain America story and the story of avengers
endgame. But as you can see since avengers
endgame has ended Hawkeye's basically been
trying to make up for lost time with his family.
I'm assuming because they feature that Captain
America musical so much that he's taking them
into New York City into the city to actually
see the musical because they know that he's
an adventure and he lived through all the
stuff but adjusting that there in a Chinese
restaurant during the holidays in New York
City. Joe Russo's daughter is back playing
a version of Lila Barton who is also called
Hawkeye big joke during avengers endgame.
Even though Kate Bishop is sort of his successor
in the whole joke that she herself is the
one who's going around the city calling herself
the deadliest archer some people are calling
me that are you some people yes big surprise
here they're not using WHIH for the new station,
but he catches the broadcast and sees somebody
wearing his ronin costume obviously. This
is Kate Bishop running around. He just doesn't
know who it is. He just thinks that somebody
has come to get him and is doing this to taunt
him. Like he says his past. Is Ronin caught
up with them. Kevin Feige did say that they
would also be covering a lot of his time as
Ronin during that five year time gap when
he was going around the world killing all
the mobsters the pie be a combination of flashbacks
him talking about it with Kate Bishop and
other villains that he did not kill coming
back to get him there's a big trope of a lot
of holiday theme stories all be home for Christmas
but not being able to make it home for Christmas
because of circumstances obviously in this
case is very dire marvel avengers circumstances.
But you think of classic holiday stories.
Like planes, trains and automobiles people
trying to make it home. But not being able
to because of crazy things around them happening.
So he says the rest of his family home and
stays in New York City where most of the series
is going to take place to deal with this quote
unquote masked vigilante this wearing his
old ronin costume will be interesting to see
how she got his ronin costume to get the brand-new
version of the marvel studios logo customized
for the Hawkeye series pretty much all the
Disney plus series all the different individual
characters, have gotten a customized version
of the logo. If you haven't read Hawkeye volume
4. It's the Matt fraction Hawkeye run that's
basically inspired most of the story. The
series. But I've said they changed a couple
plot points because of what happened in the
marvel movies so far is he Hailee Steinfeld
Kate Bishop try to take us in criminals wearing
the ronin costume and it Hawkeye swoops in
to try and stop all of them as he rips the
mascot she freaks out oh my God you're Hawkeye.
So even though you don't actually get the
story of how they originally met during this
the way they're pitching this that actually
happened during the five year time jump like
the doing a version of her comic book story,
but they're using that five year time jump
between avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame, when he was Ronin if you're not familiar
with Kate Bishop she's basically a New York
socialite born into a wealthy family. But
her father is heavily connected to the mob.
They cast Vera Famiga as her mother and she
is a huge actress, so I'm also guessing there's
gonna be big twist with who her mother, winds
up being because there was a report that Madame
mask would be one of the characters one of
the villains on the series, so she could wind
up being a twist version of Matt a mask in
the comics, Kate Bishop's mother was in a
really huge presence it was really her father
that had the ties to the mob. She follows
him one day to one of his deals with the mob
gets captured and held hostage Hawkeye, winds
up saving her as part of this big Avengers
mission. It just happens to take out the mobsters
that were holding her captive. She winds up
becoming this big Hawkeye fan girl in inspires
her to become a badass. Just like him. So
obviously they're just adding in all the Ronin
back story as part of this for the MCU version
of Kate Bishop's origin story he probably
killed a bunch of mobsters that were holding
her captive or doing something terrible with
her family during that five year time jump
in and that's when she became the Hawkeye
fan girl. But when he put the ronin costume
down she found it and then put it on and they
sort of give you the vibe of her character.
Early on. Like she's kind of fumbling her
way through being a version of Hawkeye in
the tone of the series. I would say is kind
of like diehard because like diehard is a
Christmas movie. Because it happened during
Christmas the kind of playing this. Like it's
sort of Hawkeye's version of a diehard story
with him being a very John McLean kind of
character getting caught up in this during
the Matt fraction run they shared an apartment.
This looks like them going back to a version
of that apartment this area of New York City
that you see here in this shot is near where
the old avengers tower used to be only because
this is the Christmas right after avengers
endgame. By this time somebody is getting
ready to buy the new tower of that really
isn't happening to the events of Spider-Man
far from home. Which actually happens later
after the events of this Hawkeye series. This
is more like a couple months after avengers
endgame. But after the events of falcon and
winter soldier. I was he because the whole
black widow post credit scene with yelena
belova guessing that's gonna wind up happening.
Towards the end of the episodes the be six
episodes total. By the way the marvel Disney
plus series are either longer episodes. Like
45 minutes per episode in their six episodes
per series or the shorter episodes and you.
Like nine episodes per series like what if
her Wandavision to the Hawkeye episodes will
be a little bit more like the length of the
Loki episodes them in their that funny moment
of him saying I'll be back in a day or two
to his family. They finally revealed the mid-boss
villains. So even though they seem like the
main villains of the series they're not there
called the tracksuit Mafia or the tracksuit
Dracula's, but they play them more for comedy
that comedic villains there called so because
they all wear tracksuit in the use a moving
company is a front for their operations that's
why says trust bro on the side of their van
that's within the funny moment of them trying
to throw the multi-of cocktail into the window
Hawkeye just catching it and throwing right
back Adam I was he one of the episodes is
going to be them crashing this big dinner
that's happening that probably has something
to do with the mob the because one of the
biggest parts of this is him taking Kate Bishop
under his wing in training her as his successor
you see a lot of the comedy of purchase kind
of failing it trying to be Hawkeye early on.
Like crashing to the window Steinfeld is one
of those actresses that does a pretty decent
job with this kind of comedic level of action,
then they finally introduce a version of Lucky
the pizza dog who is a big character during
the Hawkeye series Kate Bishop also winds
up taking him with her during Hawkeye volume
5 as well. He's a dog they rescue of the street.
Which is why it looks like he lost one of
his eyes in an accident this is Kate Bishop
saving people in broad daylight wearing the
ronin costume not really sure when this is
happening during the timeline of the series
because I was he a certain point. Wearing
the ronin costume and mostly start walking around
wearing the purple costume. The purple costume
is her normal costume though it seems like
this scene of Hawkeye with all these people
swinging all their weapons is actually some
sort of Renn fair cosplay situation. Like
he's not actually fighting these people, there's
pretending to fight him that he couldn't tell
this character is meant to be the Maia Lopez
version of echo, so she's actually a big daredevil
character. There's a rumor that vincent d'onofrio's
kingpin is also going to be orchestrating.
A lot of what she's doing during the series
like kingpin himself is supposed to show up
at some point during the later episodes. I
don't know that means that daredevil is also
going to make an appearance or Matt Murdock
is because there's all kinds of rumors about
him showing up during Spider-Man no way home
in some of the other series to but if you
didn't hear the news earlier this year they
confirm the doing a full blown marvel Disney
plus spinoff series for echoes character and
I believe the kingpin is supposed to be much
bigger character during that. If you're not
familiar with her character. The reason why
she's called echo is because she has very
taskmaster likability she can copy other people's
abilities she's kind of like an antihero inside
marvel, but shows up as a villain for the
first time in obviously they're doing that,
during this Hawkeye series shall be going
after them. But somebody's probably manipulating
her she's not meant to be a legit evil character
for the funny joke about him telling her that
certain trick arrows of his are too dangerous
for her to use like wait a minute you have
more dangerous arrows than this. This also
big running joke during that Matt fraction
run is them just playing with a lot of the
trick arrows that Hawkeye uses they don't
really get into that too much during the Avengers
movies like you just uses arrows never specifically
call out the different types of trick arrows
that he uses so this is the biggest missing
thing in here is Yelena belova. They're probably
saving that for little bit later on I'm guessing
that she won't shut up till the end of the
series. But obviously big theory. Everybody
wonders if she will complete her mission and
ask you wind up killing the Clint Barton version
of Hawkeye because someone is manipulating
her to make her think that he was responsible
for Natasha black widows death. That's the
way that Val told it's the man responsible
for your sister's death. Even though technically
that's not exactly what happened. He tried
to kill himself but black widow just beat
him out to it as it is the whole idea that
eventually Hailee Steinfeld Kate Bishop version
of Hawkeye will show up in a big Avengers
crossover are a young avengers crossover,
because in the next couple of years between
all the marvel Disney plus series and the
marvel movies that we have coming up when
we got in the last year. So the have all the
original young avengers characters. Now my
longer breakdown video. This will post tomorrow.
So make sure you have alerts enabled so you
don't miss that. Everybody let me know what
you think it seems like it's going to be a
really solid series. As they say it's gonna
start November 24 it'll run weekly to the
end of the year so that also means that is
going to crossover with the Star Wars book
of Boba Fett episodes, which will start in
December, they'll be like the mandalorian
season 2.5 will also be doing videos for that.
They haven't completely announced with the
schedule for that series is going to be so
once they do all just included in one of my
videos also start getting some more marvel
a turtles trailer footage as well in the next
month what you wafer everything. Everyone
click here for my full shang chi post credit
scene video and click here for my full Spider-Man
no way home sinister six trailer video you
so much for watching everyone stay safe and
I'll see you guys next video!